so you remember the endure guy yes
if there's someone that's very very
young and goes into a marriage and has
kids when they're like 18 19 20. a year
into the relationship it gets really
really abusive even though it might be
rare from what you guys think if it
would happen what would you recommend
for those people would they divorce or
do you want them to keep going in the
relationship you can't divorce and
that's not a real even though it might
be like physically abusive you got to
endure people are too you want to stick
arches
are just situation that might be in that
situation what would you recommend okay
it is such an extreme example that I
can't give a prescription for what other
people should do what about if two
people get married to have a kid and
then the wife starts cheating do you
think they should divorce
Jesus himself said in in cases of
adultery divorces do you think that
divorce is worse than physical abuse
that she's worse than physical abuse for
the children yes absolutely I think I
think I'm not going to say divorce I
mean
he's going around explaining what he
meant three days later but I did say if
there was one instance because
relationships everybody every
relationship has fights every
relationship has ups and downs anybody
who says otherwise is a liar okay
there's conflict in relationships period
even the happiest couples in the world
they have conflict anybody who denies
that like I said they're just they're
lying
I think you just substituted or slip
something in there very slickly as if it
made so your argument nobody said there
aren't conflicts in relationships nobody
said there aren't fights in a
relationship what people said is just
because those things exist doesn't mean
you put your hands on your partner
during one even once even once I don't
want a traumatized woman in my life
I don't want any history or trauma I
have dealt with those kind of [__]
nut bags and I don't ever want to deal
with it ever again I want to deal with a
normal mentally stable healthy woman so
you think you're normal
in what sense well do you think you have
healthy habits yeah you do yeah some
[__] must really hate you
because
after the last video I just got people
sending me everything what do you say I
punched a Latina [__] in the face at
Rock on what's rock on it's a club in
Japan
he lives over there
he was talking [__] to some guy I guess
people just leaking the group chats he's
talking to some guy and the guy said to
him well at least I've never been
arrested for glassing a [__] and he's
like yo why are you so sensitive are you
gonna leave next so that's the MLG
saying like why are you so sensitive why
are you bringing that up and the guy
says I'm not sensitive just giving back
some and then MLD says you act like
that's the last [__] I'll Smite on this
planet
well do you think you have healthy
habits yeah I think it's very bizarre
that's
a woman in the face and your responses
that didn't happen your responses are
you being sensitive right now why are
you bringing this up then it makes me
really think you did do that [__] also
how would you kill this for being so
disgusting personally I think a good
old-fashioned bludgeoning is the way to
go big old monkey wrench to the head and
then he posts her picture in the group
chat
want a traumatized woman in my life
time to beat Aya I'm gonna beat Aya for
not being pretty enough
I have to beat if for letting this
happen
I want to deal with a normal mentally
stable healthy woman I will glass with a
champagne bottle for the honor of the
group if this happens I'll have so much
fun and money I'm gonna I'm gonna glass
like 17 inches now mind you everything
here I've been set screen recordings for
so none of it is like edited photos so
this is him contacting somebody else
about the incident in Japan he goes you
can see the video as he's scrolling he
says hey sorry to bother you about this
this guy attacked an innocent girl
rapunzi and the police found him I heard
he did some to you is that true and the
woman in question who's Japanese she
goes yes true what him make for the girl
which I think is her broken English
yeah I know he's a real scumbag is it
true that he punched you in your face
and she says yes
what happened with the other girl
and he says are you sure it's definitely
this guy
to which she replies yes as and so a
couple other people from Japan contacted
me and said that this guy was charged
for bottling a woman in the face after
she rejected him at a club
this went to court he settled out of
court the woman has a scar across her
face she didn't want to come forward and
bring this up nor does she want to be
involved because she's been traumatized
by The Experience since I know and
people sent me messages to people that
know her and people know the incident
and all these are real I made sure they
sent me videos to show me they didn't
fake no [__] DMS and that was like a
club in Japan yeah and he's also being
charged for somebody else in Japan so
it's why am I bringing all this up
listen group chats are your business
personally I've never been in a group
chat or folks brag about punching women
in the face or take joy and talk about
how they want to kill somebody that they
saw him Bumble because they're ugly okay
but when this guy is getting on podcast
talking about he wants a well-adjusted
normal women who's not traumatized I'm
like brother do you hear yourself do you
see the stuff that you be writing and
that you want to be on a podcast telling
women like yo listen if you get hit once
or more endure endure
this is the person telling you to endure
I told you you was putting some olive
oil in some garlic you about to cook
you're like what am I reading bruh yo
look at the flick of the wrists look at
the flicker yo again maybe that's how
you guys talk in your group chats maybe
I'm unaware because I only spend my time
in two group chats and it it must be
PG-13 compared to some other people I
don't know so you guys let me know in
the comments is this normal for your
ground because if it is that maybe I
need to take all this [__] what
I don't know that's why I'm actually
asking I really don't know I do not know
he's being charged again she's got
enough cases against him
a lot of these dudes in these spaces
want to always claim they're not
anti-woman but every time you peer
behind the curtain every time you look
into it every time you find out who they
really are when the cameras aren't on it
just don't sound good
I mean it don't sound good on camera but
it sounds even worse behind closed doors
nobody online's perfect nobody online
but anybody who's trying to convince you
to stay in a situation probably doesn't
have your best interest in mind and I
also say this a lot of people from the
last video we did on this topic were
saying oh you took these guys out of
context with go play the full clip go
play the full clip you know
a lot of these guys want to sit on a
podcast and the moment some woman says
something radical like ah you know I
love to fleece men they're quick they
get off they [__] seat to put her in
their place you want to Rob men of their
money through divorce absolutely and you
should be calling these women out yeah
but then the dude sits beside you and
says you should endure if you're getting
beaten by your husband or beaten by your
wife in a marriage and all of a sudden
these same people get real quiet they
don't got much they don't get quiet they
just say that hey no man you took him
out of context yeah listen nah nah nah
keep the same man or or they'd be like
you know I don't know what to say you
know I I wouldn't know how to advise
somebody I wouldn't know well what if a
woman cheats on her husband divorce
divorce all of a sudden you got plenty
of prescriptions right you think people
can't work through some infidelity but
you think that people should stick
around through physical beatings I don't
know it's just bizarre to me when I hear
some of this stuff so sometimes it's not
even what it said sometimes what's not
said sometimes it's the change in your
energy you loud and proud when it comes
to shaming single moms and all this
other stuff but we talk about folks
being on women or be Mountain Dews all
of a sudden you don't keep that same
energy that's when you look sus keep
that same energy for everything else if
you care as much as you claim that's all
I'm saying keep going in the
relationship keep going you can't
divorce and that's not a real even
though it might be like physically
abusive you got to endure people are too
you want to stick arches
are just situation that might be in that
situation what would you recommend okay
it is such an extreme example that I
can't give a prescription for what other
people should do what about if three
days later because I guess what they're
trying to say is like if if a man is
continuously beating a woman they're
talking about physical abuse yeah right
so they're they're trying to say that
I'm saying that if a man is continuously
beating a woman in a relationship that
he that she should stay should stay and
endure the thing that's not what I said
at all but I did say if there was one
instance because
you didn't say that at all and we could
play the tape back play it I think
sometimes people get on podcasts and
start talking
and there's what they say in their head
or what they think and feel and what
they actually say outward okay I think
he's just doing some damage control now
because I think he thinks his take is
better where it's like if you get hit
once
then you know you can work things out
I'll be honest with you
I think once it's too many times
personal thoughts
go on you cooking right now things can
get heated words can be said you can
even maybe even punch a wall when you
put your hands on the other person you
cross us and this is man or woman if a
woman starts hitting you I don't even
feel that different goddamn did you put
Garlic in there why is that you're
cooking okay
I don't feel is that different I think
that's a a very strong line you're
Crossing and most of us who've never put
our hands on a partner okay well no
that's not a line you I've been in a lot
of arguments punching my girls never
come up
but maybe I don't have the experience
that's why I'm turning to you
no as a matter of fact that's something
that I told him as kids that I told her
never scream at me
if you need some time to reflect the
comments your spirits down
because of something that I did please
do so if I ask you there's something
wrong
and I see there's something wrong don't
tell me no there's nothing tell me I
want to talk about it now and we'll talk
about it later so we can calm myself
down anyway because once the the the
screaming the insult we're not insulting
people that's but that's me
some of y'all [__] wrote like
that I don't even roll like that with my
friends like I will not insult you even
insult you some [__] that he's gonna do
that's gonna piss me off or some [__]
I'm gonna do that's gonna piss me off
that's gonna piss him off I don't assume
that it comes from the place of malice
or else we have a bigger problem
you understand what I'm saying all that
to say the screaming the calling names
that's those are steps before the
hitting
you don't go from this to no listen to a
hit
[__] escalated that's just me and I said
that when I was
16 to my girl
maybe it's because of the what I saw
with that what I said what I was raped
with my parents
they had arguments and at some point I
remember that it was start to heal a bit
much but I was so not used to that that
I got past and I was like yo like are
you guys separating and stuff like that
and they were like they realized and
they said no we're just talking
but it's okay we're good went back
upstairs and they understood that they
had to lower the thing a bit because
okay now there's a car all that to say
maybe it's because of how I was raised
and yes that's a privilege
but the screaming the name calling even
before it that's a no
that's a no
don't call me names because I will say
stuff that I will not regret and once
you pass and once you say certain things
it's hard for me to turn back
the punching one time
no because there's other steps that was
crossed before that anything else you
want to say all right let us know what
you guys think in the comments below
that's a cook dinner's ready but isn't
that what it's super wild when I was
reading that [__] I was like bro I'm not
bugging this [__] weird right it's weird
it's weird you look supersus but not
only that like you said if they're
charging after that as well so you
should disregard in your comment in your
locker room talk yeah but then you got
disregard for women in being charged for
disregard for women so it's like it's
not just one incident it's not just one
thing yeah it's the repeated behavior
that happens and you're like you're
trying to connect the dot you're like
that's [__] weird yeah you're a
weirdo if it was just one thing where
you just sing some stupid [__] once that
would be one thing I'll be honest with
you if people leave my group chats you
would be super disappointed
I think I need to get a little bit more
problematic no we're good we're good
we're good because I ain't seen we're
good I ain't the stuff I came up because
this [__] no there's no game keep it
keep it trash okay